and so what i'm taking away from this is
there's a couple of different steps here
right so the first
is what i'll call uh just collection of
um the raw materials so you have to
actually get the blood or whatever it is
then there's an actual scientific
process that is identifying the cells
and and kind of
having that precision uh technology or
science that you talked about
and then now what you're talking about
is this third step which is really just
data analytics right um it's it's very
kind of high level it's very
large data sets but it's a sounds like
machine learning type
uh problem where you ultimately can say
hey we have confidence that we collected
the samples from the people that we
think we did
we've got confidence that we were able
to use our precision technology to get
accurate identification kind of the the
raw data
that we have or feeding to the machine
is accurate and then if those
machine learning algorithms and kind of
computers are are
structured correctly they should be
smarter than the average doctor
right and come back and say here is
exactly the path
uh that this person is on based on the
genomic sequencing
and then you guys almost are going to
build like a recommendation engine
after that that then says you should go
get this test or you should go do you
know x y or z
because of the machine learning has
matched you to these other people and
that's where we know how to make that
recommendation do i do i have that kind
of right
yeah i think you got very close there
are two more steps that make this whole
thing
work after that the next step is
clinical algorithms
and you know that is something you
cannot do through a machine learning
system you have to do this
you need a lot of people involved you
need to apply what's called a delphi
method
so you have to ask a lot of experts for
their opinion
and what happens under all these
circumstances right for all these
different cancers how do we what
downstream clinical diagnostics should
we
and here you cross the line from science
into medicine which is a very different
thing
so medicine is all about you know who
agrees
who are other people saying the same
thing because you have to
get to a consensus among experts
otherwise you're screwed
right you need liability out of the way
you need to implement that
so it is a very different field than
just science the scientists can just say
well i think this is the best solution
because here's my statistics
in clinical reality you have to say but
who are the people who
agree with that because it's a much more
holistic problem
and then the last step so fourth is
clinical algorithms that
this whole thing needs to work with
which is very complex that's one of the
main reasons why
smart tech guys who go into biotech
often fail because they
lack know the understanding of what goes
beyond science and engineering
what goes into this weird clinical space
you know this authority and doctors and
experts and legal and compliance but you
have to solve that otherwise you don't
have a product
and the final step is of course the
business model
like who actually pays for that and that
again sounds maybe trivial to most tech
and finance guys like why is this i mean
if you save people's lives they just pay
for it
guess what not in medicine so well
well we changed the head fundamentally
but uh
it gets insanely complicated how do you
convince a
insurance bureaucrat that he likes that
and if you
show that you save people like sorry to
be so frank but they don't
care that's not their job you have to
show them that they save money
and you have to show them that you save
money immediately or
quickly over time you know
and then you know things get insanely
complicated
and that kills also most of the
innovation so
if you don't solve four and five all
your amazing tech
is not gonna work because you can't
finance it
and so this this is like the now i gave
you the full picture and complexity why
it's
absolutely non-trivial to truly
understand your business model to
innovate on that front
and to be highly synced with the medical
and clinical reality of things
and then nailed the tech and then you're
getting somewhere
yeah it no it's absolutely nuts and i
guess part of that clinical side
um when i hear the word clinical i think
of
uh all sorts of different tests that can
be run with this genomic sequencing
stuff
uh is this only being done on humans was
it previously done on
animals and then that's where the
technology kind of was perfected and now
it's being brought to the human side
like what is the relationship there
uh in some of that testing to non-human
kind of clinical trials or whatever you
could do there well the problem is
or the advantage of genomic sequencing
is you don't have to do a lot of animal
trials because there is no risk in just
collecting the evidence
right so you that was very human driven
from the outset on
uh craig venter and the human genome
project
so you can sequence you know a lot
and you don't you know without any kind
of approval because if you do clinical
trials you just sequence
no one gets hurt as long as there's no
feedback loop um
so it's very different the the actual
sequencing and developing sequencing
technologies you're free to you know
test this on humans because
you're not putting anyone at risk
especially if there's no feedback of
information
once it gets into cancer screening of
course the
game completely changes and that's the
problem that's what's holding the little
biopsy industry back
so what we discuss is called liquid
biopsy because it's liquid and kind of a
biopsy
um and that's where we innovated a lot
to actually get out of that
problem and get medical advancements and
technologies to
our members much faster than we normally
would be able to do that
if we just go through medicare and you
know commercial insurance
got it and then i guess as you um
get better and better at this right
because part of the machine learning
algorithms that are actually analyzing
all of the sequencing
uh they should improve over time right
it's kind of the beauty of machine
learning
um help me understand uh
is that something where let's say i'm
testing for
uh a variation that we believe could uh
lead to a higher propensity for cancer
right can i use the uh the advances
and the accuracy that we've determined
on that test uh
in those machine learning algorithms to
then apply to a different type of test
like is there some
uh shared knowledge or or uh shared
analysis that can be moved from test to
test
or is each one of these tests uh when
you go to start them they're really
starting from scratch right so you have
to rewrite the algorithms and
and kind of start all over again without
any of that shared knowledge
i mean it's one of the i'm super excited
about these things because it's
probably the most challenging and
rewarding
data science problems i've ever seen um
well there are some in finders that are
also pretty immediately rewarding but i
mean in a human sense
um and you can view it as like in a way
if you take a step back
it's like any data problem right if you
want to determine something
if you want to figure out if a certain
real estate uh
you know offering is like likely to
increase in value over time
you could build a crazy machine learning
thing around it like how many people
look at it where it's listed you know
what the current price is what the stock
market does like you could feed
all that information and how does the
stock market data
relate to that real estate as opposed to
other real estate listings around it
well no one knows you can these are two
different tests right you combine these
test sets
and you know if you have sufficient data
sets you can make them work together
and that's if we test your hereditary if
you understand your hereditary variance
and we understand your somatic variants
the somatic variants are also like a
time based
uh kind of on a timeline time series
because we do that every year whereas as
you're
hereditary we don't have to do every
year because it's not going to change
so you have very different types of data
sets and
so you have to learn how to make them
compatible
but each data set adds a significant
amount of insight and dimension to
the problem
i think there are two major challenges
in medical data sets
the first one is they are often very
heterogeneous so if you have a thousand
or ten thousand patients
the probability that you have the same
data sets for these ten thousand is like
zero unless you do a super clean
clinical trial
that costs you an immense amount of
money um if this is commercial patients
then i might have your
hereditary genetics but not the next one
uh next person's i might have you
hereditary neurosomatic and good
clinical records but for the next person
i might only have hereditary and some
records
so when you build machine learning
systems it's very important to
account for that right that you sample
the comprehensiveness of data is nearly
impossible to maintain
um and just cutting it down to this to
the data dimensions that
are comprehensive is kind of stupid
because you're losing so much
information
so you need much more fuzzy you know
systems that
allow you to recognize much more things
and you also need to
embrace more you know man machine
hybrids
where you have experts and analysts
sitting in front of these things
and use the machine learning more as a
decision support system
and have these mutual interactions
that's very important in medicine
and then the ultimate problem of course
from a business perspective is
you need to close the business model
loop
in order to even get that information
right you need to figure out how do i
actually make money and create a
business model here
and that's very very hard and i'm very
happy we solved it the way we solved
because for most companies that means
you have to
just do very rigid clinical trials over
a decade
that costs you hundreds of millions of
dollars and are super inflexible
and in the end you have bad data sets
because you missed out on the most
important dimension
we see this with a bunch of our peers
that just don't have the right data sets